uh donald trump did a rally over the
weekend in selma north carolina he was
swollen he was sweaty he was slurring
out of the gate he looked particularly
disheveled and he looked very confused
by the teleprompter which of course
obama was bad for using a teleprompter
but trump uses one all the time time
the crowd was strange
and trump seemed to be kind of in a
hurry he was rushing through some of his
teleprompter moments
uh didn't seem too thrilled to be there
he told incredibly corrosive lies and
i'm not going to play even a lot of
moments for you we're going to keep this
short just i think it's important to
keep a line
on how the tone of these changes but i'm
not going to give you 15 clips we'll
just look at a few right here trump
glitching all over the place at one
point he said that they have something
on ping
i don't know what that is maybe you know
what it is listen to this but look at
this dinesh d'souza
movie and they have it on tape and they
have it on ping
they have it all over the place anybody
know what ping is
does he mean bing the search engine that
like nobody uses is it on bing
ping i don't even know what that means
and the entire speech was confused like
this it wasn't clear whether trump was
misreading things off the prompter that
he shouldn't be using because it's bad
when obama used the prompter is bad when
hillary used to prompt her it's not
clear whether it was written incorrectly
on the prompter it's not clear if ping
means something that you and i just
don't know it's all very very strange
another moment where trump seemed
visibly confused by the things he was
reading off the prompter he said that
one of the january 6th trials
this is almost comedic genius it ended
in an extortion
and if you keep listening
it it seems that what trump means is
that it ended in an exoneration
i don't know why he called it an
extortion but there's almost like a
freudian second layer meaning to it
listen to this
and as you probably have heard one of
the first january 6 trials ended
in an extortion and it was a horrible
thing what they were doing to people but
it was a horrible thing what they were
doing to people but and then i think
here he realizes he's not making any
sense there was exoneration
[Music]
because they effectively proved
that he got waved into the capitol by
the
police remember this nancy pelosi was in
charge of
the capital you know that right
and the mayor of dc they were in charge
of all security in the case now remember
that trump was asked send in the
national guard to dc
this is a semantic game that they're
talking about which as well the speaker
of the house generally oversees security
in the capital
but of course the problems started
outside the capitol they started outside
the capitol when uh crowd control
barriers were breached and trump was
asked call in please please call in the
national guard and he didn't do it so
again confused did trump mean to say
that it ended in an extortion instead of
an exoneration we don't know we we just
never know none of it makes any sense
this was very interesting trump
announced that he is endorsing mehmet oz
for senator from pennsylvania uh now
we're going to go back to this
endorsement later because megaworld is
in meltdown mode because of this it's
very interesting but check out the
credentials that trump touts for mehmet
oz here listen to this see if you can
pick up on it
by the way i endorsed another person
today dr oz in pennsylvania
dr oz
great guy good man good man harvard
educated
tremendous
tremendous
career and they liked him for a long
time that's like a poll you know when
you're in television for 18 years that's
like a poll that means people like you
but he's a did you did you notice what
he did there
he cites harvard he goes this is a
harvard educated doctor
as part of the reason why he's so
qualified but understand the hypocrisy
harvard
is woke
leftist indoctrination trash
discriminating against asian students
and
except
when they want to puff up dr oz or ted
cruz or did desantis go to harvard now i
don't remember
in that case when their people went to
harvard they go harvard it's fantastic
it's the best it's such a implicit
endorsement of these people they went to
harvard except then it's oh harvard's
trash harvard's gone woke harvard is
just liberal indoctrination which is it
guys oh right it's whichever one is
convenient to you at the time
at another very strange moment donald
trump said that he's the cleanest and
most honest human being ever created by
god
this is slightly hyperbolic yeah it's a
bit of a delusion of grandeur
i've got to be the cleanest sheriff i
think i'm the most honest human being
perhaps that god ever created perhaps
instead of yeah
very very delusional and then lastly
donald trump has been very careful not
to actually say i'm running in 2024
because he wants to sidestep campaign
finance laws i also am starting to think
trump may be laying the groundwork for
the health excuse for 2024. we'll talk
about that tomorrow i don't want to get
into that today but here is trump
basically getting as close as he
possibly can to saying he's running
without actually saying it 2024 most
importantly we are going to take back
our beautiful beautiful beautiful white
house
yeah 2024 oh sorry play it's starting to
play again there so uh there are
campaign finance reasons for which he
for why he might be doing that but also
i am going to tell you tomorrow about
this new health thing that trump is
introducing i've never heard him do it
before but he did it in an interview
with the washington post late last week
we'll talk about that tomorrow if you
listened today and didn't see the clips
i played and you're curious how bad are
the optics and they're very very bad
you'll be able to find all of these
clips on our instagram at david pakman
show
do you know the fastest growing crime in
the united states for years the rate of
this crime has been surging the crime is
identity theft and it happens way more
often than you might think
it's happened to me i've talked about
this on the show before and it can be
really bad sometimes you get a text that
your email password has been changed
your bank calls about unusual activity
your paypal account is getting drained
and it can happen very very quickly to
keep my accounts protected i use aura
our sponsor aura is identity theft
protection
fraud monitoring and password management
all wrapped into one aura monitors the
dark web for your information they
monitor your credit card they monitor
your bank accounts my subscription to
aura gives me peace of mind protects my
devices it protects all of my different
accounts and i can monitor everything in
one place on the app if i get attacked
aura actually takes action to prevent
and resolve the issues in real time and
aura is letting my audience try it
completely free for 14 days go to
aura.com
pacman the link is down below